-You know our next guests from
their massively popular show
"Impractical Jokers," which just
kicked off its ninth season.
New episodes air
Thursday nights on truTV.
Let's take a look.
-This is my dog Frank here
-Oh.
-My dog [bleep] your dog.
[ Laughter ]
So, this is the report.
-Is that what you're telling me?
-Yeah.
You know, it talks you through
the whole thing there.
-We have fake incident reports
with diagrams,
and we marked where the places
were affected.
-On Wednesday,
the staff member, Joe,
witnessed Frank laying
metaphorical pipe on Brooklyn.
This is --
-You're a big dude, man.
-Yeah, he's a big dude.
He is a big dude.
[ Laughter ]
-Hi! Come on!
Come on, Brooklyn. There you go.
-Hey!
-There you go.
-Hi, little one!
-[ Laughing ] Look at the dog.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
Joe Gatto, James Murray,
Brian Quinn, and Prince Herb
How are you, gentlemen?
-Hey!
-Hey, Seth!
-How you doing, bud?
-Hi, Seth. How are you?
-I have a lot of questions
about the clip we just saw
but I do --
Last time you were here,
there was not a Prince Herb.
This is a new moniker.
Can you explain
how that came about?
-What's up, Seth?
It's so nice to see you, buddy
Yeah, this --
I got punished this season
and they're changing
my identity.
And it's going to permeate
into my real life
for the rest of this year.
So, basically, I don't kno
if you know this.
Herb, where we're from,
means, like, a corn ball.
So, basically,
they made me pierced --
They made me --
[ Laughter ]
-Show him the bling!
Show him the bling!
-They pierced my ears.
I have to keep these in
for 6 to 12 months right now
They're changing the credits
of the show.
Any press I do,
any late night --
When I go up onstage
to do stand-up,
I get called up
as Prince Herb right now.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is my new identity.
-You're royalty, buddy!
You should be honored.
-That was very nice of the
to put a Prince in there.
-Yeah.
-You could have just been Herb
So, I mean, I was looking
at these and laughing so loud.
So, you had --
I mean, this bit of the do
groomers is just fantastic
How did you come up with it,
and what were people's reaction?
That guy was pretty affabl
about the fact you said
your dog had sex with his.
Were all the reactions
that nice?
-No, not really.
We were in Brooklyn,
so you got a good range
of people that came in.
But the guys, quite simply
was like --
I was very proud of them,
because it was a very smar
and easy punishment.
Sometimes they're just ver
simple, and simple's the best.
I worked at a doggy daycare,
when people came
to pick up their dog.
They planted this English
Mastiff named Frank there,
this huge dog. And I just
had to very simply say,
"Uh, one more thing
before you go.
My dog [bleep] your dog,"
and slide over
an incident report
that they had made
these graphics of,
like, that outlined
exactly what happened
and take people through it
-I mean, the incident report
are -- I mean, just --
So, this one,
you know, pretty basic.
That lets you know
what happened.
-Yeah, that's just the basic
[ Laughter ]
-But this, you guys,
I mean, I don't think --
-That's it.
[ Laughter ]
-Some poor person had to com
and look at that?
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That was great, because
you would watch people
go through a range
of emotions, right?
Some would be angry.
Some would be confused.
Some would be
just outright baffled.
But at the end of the day,
I mean, dogs will be dogs.
Like, it's not Joe's fault
you know?
-Hey, it's nature. You can't
be mad at me, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I am shocked
that you guys can still
pull one over on each other.
But this did happen
with Paul McCartney.
-Oh, yes.
-Explain the prank,
and tell me exactly
how surprised you were
that it worked.
-Yes, well, we have this show,
Seth, called "Dinner Party,"
and we have guests on.
We've had lots of great guests
And we heard that Paul,
Sir Paul,
was a fan
of "Impractical Jokers,"
so I reached out to him
and asked if he would
come on "Dinner Party,"
and he sent a little video i
saying hi to us
and stuff like that.
It was one of the most amazing
moments in our lives.
Unfortunately, it wasn't
really Paul McCartney.
[ Laughter ]
I hired the worst Paul McCartney
impersonator to come in,
and some of these guys --
I don't want to say who, Seth --
but they bought it
hook, line, and sinker.
-Alright. So, now,
for our viewers at home,
we're going to show this clip.
And be honest with yourselves.
Would you think
this is Paul McCartney?
Let's take a look.
-Hello, "Impractical Jokers.
-Oh, my God.
-I just wanted to say that
I'm a big fan of your program.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I'm here to confirm
that Q is indeed
my favorite joker.
-Is that real?
-Murr reminds me of Ringo...
-I --
-...in all the best ways.
I just feel that Q
is the Paul of the group.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
-I mean, when you see it now -
-I need to defend myself, Seth
-No, you don't.
-Okay, I've seen this man
my whole life.
I've seen him in concert
a few years ago.
I know all about him.
I'm a huge fan.
Here's the thing.
I did not want to --
I suspended disbelief.
I didn't want to --
In my head, I'm like, "This ma
is falling on hard times.
He's had multiple
strokes recently.
He's put on the pounds."
But I was like,
"If this is really him,
I cannot insult him."
So, I just bought into the fac
that it was him,
but it's not fair of you all
to mock me.
-Yeah, it is!
-No.
-I'll tell you what, Seth,
if there's a 1% chance that that
was actually Paul McCartney,
we had to 100% say
that that was Paul McCartney
-Yeah.
-We had to.
-We had no other choice.
-Also, in the, like, long life
of things you guys have done
that's embarrassing,
it's not like
anybody's going to remembe
you thought
that was Paul McCartney.
I think you're in the clear.
-You're right.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Murr, I have a question.
First of all, congratulations.
You just got married.
-Boom! Yes. Thank you, sir
-And I have a genuine question
Like, obviously, your wife knows
the world
that she's marrying into.
Does she live in dread
that you will become victi
of one of these --
of the imagination
of your three friends?
-No, sir.
They use her against me.
My wife has a degree in nursing.
So, a few weeks ago,
I came home,
and the guys had
a urologist there.
And they put a catheter in me,
and then they had my nurse wif
take it out of me
after they made me ride a zi
line holding my own catheter
So she's loving it.
[ Laughter ]
-We're actually using
a lot of Murray's holes
for punishments here,
because we also made him
the national spokesperson
for My Shiney Hiney,
which is a real product.
-Yeah, this is a real product,
a real billboard.
"Kiss dark, cavernous
butt holes goodbye."
That is --
[ Laughter ]
-That stands in New Jersey
right now, right now.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm the face of anal bleaching.
-Not just the face,
it should be noted --
-We have the best job
in the world.
-The happy face of --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, I want to ask you guys
a last question,
'cause we're running
a little out of time.
You had a -- In February, which,
it should be noted, obviously,
was right before the whole world
went to hell in a handbasket
you had two things happen
that then stopped happening.
You had a movie premiere,
and you also had
an "Impractical Jokers" cruise
-Yeah, we're single-handedly
responsible
for about 100,000 cases
of COVID.
We just super-spread.
[ Laughter ]
We super-spread.
That's what we do.
-That's what we do. Yeah.
-We have single-handedly -
We have single-handedly ende
both cruises and cinema.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of, Seth,
this is our third time on.
Do you want my address
for the third mug, or --
-Where do we get that?
-We are going
to give you a third mug.
You know, obviously,
one mug for the group.
-Alright.
-Hey, gentlemen, I want to end
by saying congratulations
both on Season 9
and on Season 10.
You guys got picked up.
I mean, it is the hardest thin
in the world this year
to do shows for 10 seasons
You guys deserve it.
It's very clear you love
what you do, because otherwise
what on earth
would you be doing it for?
[ Laughter ]
-Very true. Very true, Seth.
Thanks. Yeah, we're excited.
It's been a great ride.
And, you know,
people seem to enjoy it,
so we're just
going to keep doing it
till they, you know, bury me
-Well, congratulations, guys
[ Laughter ]
Always a pleasure.
Come back soon.
It's great talking to you.
-Thank you, Seth.
-"Impractical Jokers"
airs Thursday nights on truTV.